hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir
endlich eines meiner lieblings rezepte
aus russland nämlich die methodik torte
und das ist man richtig leckere
honigkuchen der ist ganz leicht
zeitaufwendig aber auch nicht so viel
und anlässlich der fußball wm gegen
russland stattfindet kann ich euch
endlich zeigen es gibt also keine
ausreden mehr
denn ich hab das schon so lange auf
meiner liste und jetzt starten wir
zuallererst mit unserem zuckersirup im
grunde genommen ist es gar kein zucker
sirup sondern einfach nur zucker wasser
denn wir machen uns das jetzt sehr
einfach wenn ihr mir abgekochtes wasser
das noch sehr heiß ist und geben das zum
zucker
[Musik]
durch das heiße wasser lösen sich jetzt
die zuckerkristalle und anschließend
geben wir das zum abkühlen an die seite
und jetzt kommt der anstrengende teil
aber ich vermisse euch ist auch nicht so
anstrengend ist nur ein bisschen
zeitaufwendig und zwar unser tag
dafür benötigen wir eier honig mail
außerdem natron es sich und eine prise
salz und für den teig geben wir
zuallererst eier mit honig in unsere
küchenmaschine ihr könnt natürlich auch
ein handgerät verwenden ist gar kein
problem und das schlagen wir dann so
ungefähr 23 minuten die prise salz kommt
jetzt auch noch mit rein das hebt
nochmals in den süßen geschmack und dann
wird das klinik gerührt
[Musik]
nach ca 4 minuten auf höchster stufe ist
der teil zu viel heller gewonnen und so
ein bisschen cremig und jetzt machen wir
weiter
und zwar hier nebenan habe ich schon
natron und essig bereitgelegt ihr könnt
wenn ihr kein natron da habt auch
backpulver nehmen die gleiche menge
einfach aber nah dran arbeitet ein
bisschen besser im teig
jetzt werden die beiden zutaten einmal
kurz miteinander verrührt und der essig
sorgt dafür dass das natron sofort
aktiviert wird und dass man besser ein
bisschen besser arbeitet durch die säure
und dann gehen wir das mit zum teil und
anschließend noch das mehl und dann wird
das noch mal gut untergerührt
[Musik]
das mehl das am rand noch so ein
bisschen noch nicht ganz im teig
verarbeitet ist ist nimmt jetzt noch mal
schön mit und dann noch einmal ganz kurz
unterrühren
[Musik]
ich zeige mich jetzt ganz kurz die
konsistenz unseres honigtau also ein
bisschen wie so eine art muffin teig
kann man schon sagen so und ich weiß es
gibt verschiedene rezepte es gibt auch
rezepte in denen ihr dann so einen
schweren tag erhalte den ihr
anschließend ausfallen ist ich finde die
version am einfachsten und auch am
leckersten ich habe viele versionen
ausgetestet und ihr wisst ja ich
präsentiere ich gerne immer das
einfachste was aber trotzdem sehr lecker
ist wir benötigen als nächstes unser
backblech und die normalsten oder
generell haben wir immer zwei backbleche
das heißt wir können jetzt hier immer
nacheinander arbeiten der ofen des
vorgeheizt auf 170 grad ober und
unterhitze das ist auch ganz wichtig und
jetzt verteilen wir immer ganz dünn
unseren tag auf das blech und
verstreichen das
[Musik]
so er hat gesehen der teig geht ganz
dünn verstrichen also wirklich hauchdünn
man kann schon fast das papier
untendrunter sehen aber eben nicht ganz
also ihr müsst ja so ein bisschen die
mitte finden und jetzt wird das gebacken
für ungefähr sieben minuten im
vorgeheizten backofen also bei mir sind
sie minuten bei euch kann das auch
variieren
deshalb schaut auf jeden fall nach dass
es nicht zu dunkel wird sondern wirklich
nur goldbraun und so machen wir jetzt
immer so weiter ich arbeite parallel ich
habe mir mein zweites ich schon und dann
machen wir das bis der teig zu ende ist
so ich habe jetzt schon ein bisschen was
vorbereitet ich zeige euch gerade mal
den boden so muss er aussehen und nicht
dunkler also richtig schön goldbraun und
das was wir jetzt benötigen ist
irgendein 100 gegenstand sei es ein
teller oder ein tortenring ich mir zum
tortenring habe den auf 18 cm
eingestellt und jetzt stechen und
schneiden wir uns die kreise aus
[Musik]
und übrigens diesen schritt mit dem
ausschneiden das müsst ihr direkt machen
nachdem es aus dem ofen kommt denn
ansonsten wird das ein bisschen fest und
dann könnt ihr das gar nicht mehr und
ausschneiden und die ränder die jetzt
übrig bleiben die müssen wir ebenfalls
aufbewahren also klar ihr könnt ein
bisschen was naschen gebraucht nicht
alles aber wir brauchen einiges davon
also nicht irgendwie wegwerfen oder
abgase weglaufen schon mal gar nicht
aber auch nicht abgeben
[Musik]
die böden die gebe ich übrigens jetzt
unter einem sauberen küchentuch damit es
nicht austrocknet das ist auch ganz
wichtig denn die werden wirklich sehr
schnell hart übrigens habe ich einen
ganz wichtigen hinweis für euch also die
erste ladung brauchte bei mir sieben
minuten die zweite nur noch sechs und
die dritte vierte fünfte und so weiter
die brauchen nur noch fünf minuten
dh ihr müsst immer ein auge drauf werfen
also verspricht mir dass wir da immer
ein auge auf dem ofen habt und schaut
dass das ganze nicht zu dunkel wird dann
macht ihr alles richtig und wir können
rief leckeren kuchen später genießen
meine fertigen böden habe ich jetzt
immer noch sicher oder dem küchentuch
versteckt es sind übrigens insgesamt
zwölf stücke auf ok dilara von der
schule bekommen so weitergeht so und
hier habe ich jetzt für die deko noch
meine restlichen überbleibsel von dem
teig und diesen auch schon halb gewonnen
die hatte ja nicht unter dem tuch und
das brauchen wir auch denn jetzt müssen
wir die noch mixen oder klein hacken in
unserem mixa da gebe ich jetzt einfach
so eine hand voll rein
[Musik]
zusätzlich zu dem teig geben wir noch
eine handvoll walnüsse denn ihr wisst ja
walnüsse und honig das passt unglaublich
gut zusammen
[Musik]
so das haben wir vorbereitet jetzt geht
es weiter mit der leckeren creme und die
ist super einfach das entschuldigt so
ein bisschen den aufwand von gerade weil
das wirklich sehr schnell geht ich habe
hier ganz einfach saure sahne könnt ihr
auch durch creme fraiche oder durch
schmandt ersatz ins werk ein problem
und dann habe ich hier noch
karamellisierte und gezuckerte
kondensmilch ihr bekommt auch gezuckerte
kondensmilch ja die bekommt die überall
die kanalisierte konsens nicht die
bekommt ihr in den großen supermärkten
in dieser russischen abteilung und das
ist noch mal so next level sagen ich
immer gerne weil das schmeckt noch mal
so richtig lecker weil das eben
karamellisiert ist wenn das nicht
bekommt kann auch ganz einfach das gegen
die gezuckerte kondensmilch ersetzen
aber vertraut mir damit schmeckt einfach
unglaublich lecker
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir alles vorbereitet und
der spaßige teil kann beginnen wir
schichten und füllen jetzt den boden und
ihr wisst ja jetzt ist der boden noch
nicht ganz so software wird durch das
zuckerwasser und durch die creme später
nach der kür zeit noch richtig schön
weich ich zeige euch jetzt die
reihenfolge wie ihr das ganze schichten
müsst
[Musik]
wir sind schon fast fertig fast am ende
angelangt jetzt fehlt nur noch eine
entscheidende sache
wir müssen wir jetzt noch den ganzen
kuchen bedecken mit unseren krümeln und
mit den walnüssen und dann ist aber
wirklich fertig
[Musik]
unsere methodik torte sieht so schon
fertig aus aber ihr müsst eine sache
noch beachten und zwar die kühl zeit die
ist ganz wichtig bei diesem rezept denn
erst nach der schulzeit kann alles so
ein bisschen allem ziehen und die torte
wird richtig schön weich und ihr könnt
sie auch ordentlich anschneiden das
heißt gibt sie entweder zu sechs stunden
in den kühlschrank oder über nacht dass
es vollkommen euch überlassen hauptsache
erhaltet die kühl zeit so ein bisschen
ein
[Musik]
guck mal so ehrlich bin ich habe extra
weil wir gerade die aufnahmen brauchten
damit ihr sehen könnt wie soft das ist
die habe ich nicht vergessen
normalerweise esse ich die immer sofort
aber ich bin unbedingt jetzt vor der
kamera mal probieren so ich bin gespannt
ich weiß auch schon was steckt da war
ich hab seit langem weg ist
hmm
ganz ehrlich
also wenn ihr honig möglich ist dass ein
wahrgewordener traum ehrlich das ist so
lecker man hat das gefühl weil das so
soft ist man ist quasi nichts keine
kalorien hat mir das gefühl dass vom
geschmack her dass bombe eine
geschmacksexplosion geil aber irgendwie
das gefühl kalorien technisch ist man
nichts weil ich das so leicht anfühlt
als ob da nichts im magen werden
honig ist ja gesund deshalb ist der
kuchen auch natürlich diät geeignet ist
er klar
eine echt super lecker ja recht bestimmt
hat ähnlichkeit mit einem baum kuchen
schmeckt aber einzigartig lecker ich
empfehle es euch läge es euch so sehr
ans herz wie fast kein anderes video und
genau die genauen mengenangaben steht
immer hier und in der infobox ich freue
mich auf eure fotos darauf freue ich
mich am meisten mit dem hashtag
diskretion noch ins gras und dann freue
ich mich wenn du beim nächsten mal auch
wieder einschaltet ja ein schöner ist
[Musik]
ich will auch was haben jemand drei den
hut auf dem kopf ja heute noch genau
darauf jeden tag essen jeden tag